he says matter is crystal is a
crystalline structure
of photons ether medium particles
squeezed
into a crystalline structure but then he
follows that up and says you know
quantum ether cannot have material
existence what am i
what is he what is their problem here
the problem is that he starts out saying
matter is blah blah blah and then he
says quantum is not
matter it's not have material it cannot
have material existence
and so we have to look up the word
matter here's the the wikipedia
and uh to find out what matter is
according to quantum mechanics
and it says in classical physics and
general chemistry
right so we're not talking about quantum
right matter is any
substance that has mass and takes up
space by having volume
it does not include massless particles
such as photons or other energy
phenomena or waves such as light or
sound
matter exists in various states solids
liquid gas
and also they say plasma bose einstein
condensates fermionic condensates quad
gluon plasma et cetera
so they have these different states so
what are they referring to well they're
saying anything that has
volume and takes up space and has mass
okay
and it continues says now you get to the
quantum part okay
here's the the fine print usually atoms
can be imagined as a nucleus of protons
and neutrons and a surrounding cloud of
orbiting
electrons which take up space however
this is only somewhat
correct so there you get the fine print
because
subatomic particles and their properties
are governed by their quantum nature
which means they do not act as everyday
objects appear to act they can act like
waves as well as particles and they do
not have well-defined sizes or positions
okay so they there's the qualifier okay
in the standard model of particle
physics matter is not a fundamental
concept because the elementary
constituents of atoms are quantum
entities which do not have an inherent
size or volume in everyday sense of the
word
so with that they they were able to
weasel
out of the definition they don't have a
definition of matter
uh because you say well is an electron
matter well it is a matter when it's a
particle
and it has volume and it has mass but uh
when it's spread out and turns into a
wave well at that point where all bets
are off
we don't call it matter anymore now we
call it energy and so
you know when matter turns into energy
well you know we're talking about a
different word and we don't know what
energy is
and so uh you know we're left with this
uh what is matter
i mean is an electron matter or not
the other issue with that is that you
know they say that even macroscopic
macroscopic particles right uh
also have wave-like characteristics
in other words even we beings humans
we have wave-like characteristics it's
just uh
that you know it's um more visible
or more detectable or more measurable in
uh
subatomic particles those vibrate and so
you say oh yeah it could be
a wave it could be a particle but us
we're so concentrated you know in
ourselves
you know in our in our bodies a rock
that it does vibrate but its vibration
is
is minimal compared to its uh particle
nature to its
you know um uh
to the fact that it's an object that it
occupies
a definite space and so you know for
that matter then nothing is matter
because if everything vibrates in the
universe and you know
we can't call anything matter and that's
why they can't define the word
so so the bottom line there is no
definition for the word matter
and so when this fellow here uh says you
know that um or is it um
that matters uh blah blah blah and then
he says but
uh quantum ether cannot be have material
existence
well at this point you know we don't
know what he's talking about and
you know what does that mean uh i mean
the ether is there or it's not
what do you mean it doesn't have
material existence there's nothing
narrow there is or something there
so on the one hand they say look it's
made of particle and anti-particle pairs
but there's no physical existence
so it's like we're saying what contours
each part of each thing in the universe
what con
what contours the moon you know what's
around the moon
and they say well you know it's uh it's
the ether
is that matter because i mean it's made
out of particle and anti-particle pairs
right
that that sea in which the moon swims
that ocean and the answer is well yeah
but we can't consider that matter
why because well because it's spread out
into ways and you know and
they jumble up the the answer and they
say well
we don't want to deal with that issue we
don't know what matter is so they use
the word matter and then they say well
it's not material and you say what did
you mean by that oh we don't know
because we don't have a definition for
matter that's the answer
okay so um in how do we do it in
rational science uh in science we have
no problem
rational physics defines these things
very precisely
so that you can follow the presenter's
uh
presentation okay here it is here's the
dissertation
uh founded on on these foundations okay
it says um first of all you know first
priority is define your key terms you
got to define the terms that make or
break your theory
that's a cynic that's the first step
always so if you define your terms
people can follow your presentation you
cannot say
oh matter what did you mean by matter oh
i don't know what i mean by matter
because the
the particle can turn into a wave and
then we don't know and blah blah blah
you know so they
put all these fine prints here's
straightforward what is something that
which has shape what is nothing
antonym of something that which doesn't
have shape we're done
uh space um
void vacuum and nothing are all synonyms
it's that which doesn't have shape
that's what space is okay that's why
when you look out there at the black sky
other than the matter that you see in
between that dark stuff just the dark
stuff
that's nothing that's absolutely nothing
there's no
uh particle there making up that black
nothing
okay uh doesn't mean that there's not
anything crisscrossing it that we can't
see that's a separate issue
what i'm saying the the black part is
not made of anything
that's the point the the black part is
is the background and
it's uh not infinite because it's not a
physical object and it's not made of
anything it's exactly what i just said
it's that which doesn't have shape
uh what is distance separation between
two objects or two somethings
location is the set of distance of one
object to all others and now we can
define the word exist
very important here uh physical presence
something that has
location uh the table i'm thinking of or
dreaming of
that one doesn't have location okay so
that doesn't exist
superman doesn't exist uh maybe his
colors exist
um you know on a paper paper in the
color and the pen
or the ink those exist but not superman
okay and what does matter matter is a
subset of
exist matter is only those objects that
exist
form what is called matter objects that
don't exist like the ones i'm thinking
about you know the table that i'm
thinking of those do not
form part of matter